احمد زاهر 25 سؤال لازم بسرعه من غير
تفكير دور توصف بانه دور عمرك
دور عمري
فتحي البرنس
على وشك الموت بسببها ايش تعلمت من هذه
التجربه
يعني
اخرته يعني مش لازم نحارب ونعمل ونتخانق
على ادوار وعلى حاجات الدنيا زي يعني
وتعلمت كمان ان انا لازم اقرب من ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى اكتر انت ابو البنات الله
يخليهم لك
ولد
يكون عندي ولد وفي كل مره هدى كانت بتبقى
حامل فيها كنت باتمنى ان الحمل ده هيبقى
ولد بس ربنا
يبقى احلى اربع بنات في الدنيا فانا الحمد
لله مكتفيه ومش عايز حاجه في الدنيا غيره
ما شاء الله
اييي
يعني حاسسني بالمسؤوليه اكثر لان انا كنت
الراجل بتاع امي يعني حتى من وانا طفل
صغير فكان كان دايما عندي مسؤوليه ان هي
لوحدها فانا لازم اكون جنبها لازم اعمل
لها كل حاجه فاهمه لان ما فيش بابا موجود
معانا علشان هو اللي يتصرف يعني فده خلاني
مسؤول من وانا صغير
اتاسيوم في حياتي همم
يمكن وفاه جدتي امي لان انا كنت متعلق بها
قوي يعني كل حاجه في حياتي يعني الله
يرحمه ويحسن اليه
مع احد غيرك
دور رفضته ونجح جدا
الخط الاحمر
هم نفسهم عندهم خط احمر يعني هما انا
ربيتهم كويس عرفتهم كل حاجه بشكل مضبوط
عرفتهم اللي ليهم واللي عليهم عرفتهم
دينهم عرفتهم كل حاجه في الدنيا وهم اللي
بقى ده رايهم وبعدين انا باقول لهم ان انا
همم
عندي خطوط حمراء انا حاططها لنفسي عمري ما
عملتها فهما ماشيين على نفسها طيب احداث
فيلمك للفنان الراحل نور الشريف وسميت
واحده من بناتك نور على اسمه
استاذ نور الشريف ده يعني
هو كل حاجه بالنسبه لي يعني هو هو استاذي
وابوي
والاكتشفني يعني هو جاء المعهد شاف طلبه
بيمثلوا في المعهد صغيرين في سنه اولى
قال انا عايز الولد ده فجاه لقيته مقابلني
كده حتى انا اتخضيت اول ما شفته يعني ايه
ده معقول انا مش مصدق نفسي انا واقف قدام
الاستاذ نور الشريف قال لي انت ممثل شاطر
قوي وانا عايزك معايا وتعدي سنه سنه انا
قلت خلاص نسيني يعني ما بيقابل ناس وبيقول
لهم انتم كويسين وخلاص يعني لقيته بعد سنه
بيبعثوا لي في مسلسل الرجل الاخر اللي هو
كانت بدايه انطلاق النجوميه احمد زاهر
بفضل نور الشريف وانا بصراحه اتعلمت منه
كل حاجه علمت منه تركيز في الفن تعلمت منه
تواضع تعلمت منه الاجتهاد اتعلمت منه
الواحد لو مشهد واجتهد عليه ممكن يعلم به
مش لازم يبقى قد كده يعني صح
185 بعدين نحفظ جدا هل عملت عمليه تنحيف
انا
الزياده الوزن دي كانت بسبب الغده الدرقيه
انها توقفت ده مرض بيجي الواحد كل 10
مليون شخص ده اسمه ماكس ديما ده بيجي يوقف
الغده عن العمل يعني مش لازم تتشال او
يتعمل عمليه او حاجه زي كده لا هي وقفت عن
العمل فخلت وزن 185 كيلو وانا قعدت سنه
ونصف مش فاهم انا عندي ايه اصلا
وبعد كده عرفت
فلما بدات اخذ الالتروكسين او
الليفوثايروكسين اللي هو بيدي مكان افراز
الغده همم بدا الجسم يبقى في حرقه لان اول
ما كانش فيه حاجه ما كنتش عارف اخس فرجعت
بقى لعبتي بتاعه زمان
اعمل دايت قعدت سنه كامله في الموضوع ده
لغايه لما قدرت صح بالضبط
محمد سامي ده اخويا وحبيب قلبي وصديق عمري
ومحمد سامي في كينيا غريبه جدا جدا يا
ساره ما بيني وما بين يعني لدرجه انها
بتوصل ان احنا ممكن نبص لي بصه فاقول له
اوكي اوكي فهمت ما تجيش ما تقولش حتى
الناس ممكن يشوفوني يقولوا ايه المجانين
دول ده ما حدش في النطق ما حدش فيهم يتكلم
فهموا بعض ازاي احنا واصلين للمرحله دي
انا ومحمد لما بنجتمع على دور اا بيطلع
جامد جدا وبيعمل بوبه وباخذ فيه جوائز
يعني انا اكثر جوائزى اللي انا اخذتها في
حياتي في نفس الخمس اعمال اللي عملتهم مع
محمد
بيتهمك بفرض بناتك على الوسط الفني كيف
بترد
اقسم بالله ابدا عمري ما فرضتهم يعني
بدايه من اول عمر وسلمى وكابتن هيما ده
كان اختيار تامر حسني لانهم متربيين يعني
على يدين تامر يعني شافهم وهم صغيرين قد
كده هو اللي قال ان عندهم موهبه حتى انا
قلت له يعني لا تامر ممثل شاطر وبتاع مش
عايز بناتي يطلعوا يفضحوني انا ما اعرفش
اذا كانوا هم موجودين ولا لا قال لي والله
اقسم بالله بقول لك موهوبين فا بعد ما
نجحوا مع تامر بقى كل الناس بيكلموني
عايزين ملك عايزين ليلى طب انا المفروض
اقول لهم لا يعني
موجودين
الواسطه ما بتنفعش افضل واسوا صفات زوجتك
افضل صفه همم
[موسيقى]
حنينه بمئه راجل يعني حنينه وبنيه راجل
كمان يعني هي اكثر واحده وقفت جنبي في
مرحله دي وضحت بكل شيء علشان تفضل جنبي
لدرجه ان انا في وقت من الاوقات كنت حاسس
ان انا خلاص باموت همم طلقتها علشان
تسيبني وتمشي علشان ما تتعذبش معي في
المرحله اللي جايه رفضت تمشي من البيت
وفضلت قاعده معي فانا دي دي ست ب 100 راجل
يعني همم دي افضل صفه اسوا صفه ممكن تكون
همم مش عارف والله هي جميله ما فيهاش صفقه
وحشه
همم احمد يا حبيبتي ممكن الكسل شويه طيب
اوكي اوكي
الله يخليكم لبعض ان شاء الله يا رب
والله وفي اكثر من العمل لان مش شرط ان
البني ادم يعني كل اختيارات وتبقى صح رغم
ان انا دايما مركز في اختياراتي يعني ممكن
اقعد بالسنه والسنتين والثلاثه ما اشتغلش
عوامل اه في عوامل كثير بتجبر الواحد ان
هو ساعات ممكن ظروف ماديه ممكن حاجات مش
عيب يعني همم ممكن فيلم كلم ماما همم يعني
انا كنت ندمان عليه همم ممكن في فيلم اسمه
كلب دليلي مع سامح حسين انا كنت ندمان على
شكل في لان انا اضطريتني ظروف الماديه ان
انا اشتغل هذا الفيلم وانا كنت في وزن ما
كنتش احب ان انا اصلا
هل محمد رمضان نمبر وان
الله اعلم يعني انا مش المفروض ان انا
اقيم زمايلي ما ينفعش ولا زمايلي المفروض
يقيموني ده دي حاجه للجمهور الجمهور بس هو
اللي يقول
الاهلي
لكن القلب وما يريد مين اللي عندك انك
تضعف تجاهها
بناتي
والله الاربعه اقسم لك بالله
احلى حاجه في حياتي طيب
ههه
طيب الظهور في برامج المقالب بيضيف للفنان
او بيقل لي منه
هو انا مش شايف انه لا بيضيف ولا بيقلد
يعني انا شايف الا لو في تهزيء وانا لا
اقبل بالتهذيب على الاطلاق خالص ان يعني
في برنامج معين مشهور جدا جدا بقى لهم خمس
سنين بيحاولوا يحصلوا علي وانا في كل مره
باكتشف اللعبه ورفض ليه لان البرنامج ده
فيه تهزيق في الحوار على ان في الكلام اه
اه اه ما ما لا اثناء الحلقه كلها في همم
تعليقات فيها تهزيق فانا انا ارفضها لكن
انا عملت مقالب مع ناس محترمه زي الاستاذ
هاني رمزي زيدان فيفي عبده وما بقاش عارف
المقلب على فكره عشان بس الناس يقول لك كل
الممثلين عارفين لا انا عمري في حياتي ما
كنت عارف يعني لو اعرف مش هاروح فهماني بس
في واحد يقدم لك بشكل محترم وفيه واحد
يهزق الواحد انا لا اقبل التازيه اوكي هل
تشعر ان ظهورك بطل في الاعمال تاخر
يمكن يمكن يكون اتاخر ولكن انا طول عمري
يا ساره طول عمري راضي بالاسمه لي ربنا
لان لو ربنا مش رايد مش هيحصل ولو رايق
هيحصل فهماني فانا طول عمري باقول الحمد
لله وفضل ونعمه مهما اتاخر حتى لو انت
بتقول انا عندي 60 سنه مش فارق معايا
امم
[موسيقى]
كان في مشهد اييي عملته مش فاكر في مسلسل
ايه تقريبا في مسلسل علاقات خاصه كنت حكيت
في مشهد كده حاجه حصلت مع مع مع الاب يعني
همم
اثرت فيا لان انا انا اللي قائل الكلام ده
يعني انا اللي ضفته في المشهد لان ده موقف
حصل لي فانا اللي ضفته وانا بقوله كنت
متاثر قوي قوي قوي يعني مقصر في لغايه
دلوقت
لا مش فاكرها بالضبط بصراحه بس يمكن
المشهد ده اكثر مشهد اثر فيه لانه حقيقي
لانه حصل انت فاهمه يعني حقيقيه مش مش
مجرد ان انا تعايشت مع شخصيه وعملتها بصدق
لا هو موقف حقيقي حصل عشان كده انا تعبت
منه قوي
كبرت دماغي يعني عارفه ناس فاضيه يعني
قاعدين وراء البطانيه ما وراهمش لا شغل
ولا مشغله وقاعدين يشتموا في الناس خلاص
طيب اي شخص يخطب واحده من بناتك لازم يكون
مستعد لايش لمقابله الوحش
[موسيقى]
طيب كم مره حبيت
حبيت
في ثالثه اعدادي تقريبا كان طبعا يعني
المفروض ان هو مش حب يعني بس انا وقتها
كنت حاسس ان انا باحبك
ده كان حب جامد جدا جدا وبعدين همم الحب
الاقوى بقى كان امراتي الحمد لله
مليون مره وما امل ااام ده كثير قوي ههه
لا ده كثير قوي مش واحد بس مش عارف ممكن
اقول لك ايه ممكن اقول لك مثلا ذا
سكورز الفوكيت
فيلم ريتشارد برايمر ادوارد نورتون
والواحد كل ما بيتفرج بيتعلم صح طيب فتحي
في البرنس
في وسط العصبيه
جدا جدا ومع ذلك
دي حاجات كثير جدا حطوها بصور ومش عارف
ايه على على الانترنت يعني وانا كنت بموت
يعني انا عندي مشهد رعبك وانت جالس مع
روجينا وهي
رز الرعب في عيونك كان يدرس ههه
[موسيقى]
حبيبتي